Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin counters again going over your genetic pathway some more videos for you to
learn what
The way I look at things when I'm looking at your profile. So this section here would be under folate
Section of your report to the get this looks just a wee bit difference. This is
report that's
That is for the practitioner report
But the folate pathway right here is what we're looking at and when we look at the folate pathway
We're talking about this section of your whole metabolic pathway. It looks really complicated, but this is when you eat
leafy greens
You're consuming those leafy greens. It's going down this pathway here to ultimately down to the empty HFR
gene which you hear so much about to make
Five methyl tetrahedral folate in order to feed the methydine pathway to be the main methyl donor
Through CME here that donates a methyl group to turn on and off all your genes in your body
So this is a very important pathway
It's important to don't really quickly that synthetic folic acid that's in so many of our breads and pastas and things like that is
Blockes this pathway. So do not ever use synthetic folic acid. Don't take a
Product like a supplement that has folic acid as
folic acid it will never say synthetic folic acid, but it'll say
folic acid if it says folic acid as
Five methyl tetrahedral folate. Well, that's a good product. It doesn't mean it's good for you to use
But it's not the synthetic folic acid
But that's on a number of my other videos. So these are the genes that we're looking at in the folate pathway
So we look at your genetic report. We're looking at these genes right here the
FOLR genes the DHFR genes and the MTHFR genes with the Schmidt genes as well
So this is your folate pathway
The main genes in that pathway
Really important. Now this person doesn't really have bad
Arleonyne defects in their folate pathway. Now the two genes in this entire pathway that you'll hear about
Adnauzia are the MTHFR1298 this one right down here and the MTHFR C677T
Here and these you could say are the most important, but in my mind they're not really
Necessarily the most important all these genes are important all these genes are important this entire
Picture is important. These aren't any more important
But these have a lot of research out of because these are the MTHFR 6777 was one of the first genes discovered and it just has more research than probably any genes in this whole pathway
But a defect in there definitely
Causes a decrease in a person's ability to detox
You add that if like this person does not have that defect if you add that to other defects in the other
Detoxification pathways that we've already talked about in other videos that you have some even bigger issues to deal with
The 1298 mainly feeds the biopterate pathway which isn't on this but the biopterate pathway if a person has a defect like this individual does a two on the 1298 gene there
They're going to really push the biopterate pathway and they're going to have more mood issues mood mood issues
So look at the
The defects in that pathway which is way down here
Transmitters this is the biopterate pathway like this person is a lot of M.A.O.G. defects a lot of dopamine defects and a lot of
GAD defects so you add that up with
slide way back up with a
Double-leal defect right there almost I guess defect of their 1298
They're going to have a lot more issues with mood stabilization problems
So that's how you want to look at the whole big picture here
So technically I really wouldn't support this pathway at all side note is if a person is taking a bunch of
So some some people look at these reports and they really don't know how to look at the big picture not to criticize other doctors
But I see this a lot where
Let's say this individual may have come to me and was taking
five
Methyl tetrahydrofolate product a methylated folate and
Methylated vitamin B12 because this person also has a lot of B12 issues. So they were put on a
methylation products so methyl groups the problem with that is that
Because of all the defects that this individual has in the neurotransmitter genes and
Because of their
MTH of our 1298 defect they will really push that pathway hard and they'll it'll make them even worse
So you got to be really careful with that
But so in this individual right here
I would not even recommend support of this pathway at all
You certainly would not give methyl products to someone who has this
Even though it's contrary to what most doctors do it's the it's still the wrong thing to do
So I would not give methyl products if they are taking methylated products, which is like a methyl folate or
a methyl cabolamine, which is a methyl B12. I would take them off of that
So real important we're looking at this pathway right here very important pathway to feed
the methylid and
Sammy and your methyl donor which what that means is that's what turns your genes on and off. So it's a really important pathway.
so
That help, hopefully it helps I know for some of you you're looking cross-eyed right now, but
Keep studying these and you'll start it'll start to click and you'll understand the method of my madness when I do or don't
Recommend supplementation for a specific pathway. All right again if you need deeper help if you just signed up for the
JEC review and without talking to me you need to talk to me
That is also available to just call and schedule a case review to our office and if you're just caught this video on YouTube or something
hookupcuttersclinic.com
Thanks much. Hope it was a blessing